[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau cette ut cossette 8 échos
dédié à la création d'entreprises sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
on ne peut parler de start-ups en faire
un point sur le ski cube c'est le nouvel
emblème de l'ambition économique du
territoire
il réunit dans un même lieu un
incubateur la maison de l'entreprise et
un tiers ce vieux
cet espace permet un accompagnement sur
mesure des entrepreneurs et plus il ya
d'autres outils sur le territoire qui
aide à créer son entreprise
mais tout d'abord on passe au sommaire
nous ferons un point sur l'entreprise
mtu et aime la start up propose des
solutions de gestion de l'éclairage
public
elle fait partie des premières
entreprises à avoir investi le ski cube
focus sur le haut john parkes
d'elancourt nous verrons lors de ce
reportage pourquoi le financement est un
point important pour l'évolution d'une
entreprise
et puis invités de ce numéro jean-luc
méro directeur de la maison de
l'entreprise et philippe moreau le
directeur d'un cube année ans mais tout
d'abord faisons un point sur le monde de
l'entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ccnmi
d'établissements français internationaux
et près de 145 mille emplois dans des
secteurs d'activité diversifiés et c'est
le deuxième pôle économique de l'ouest
parisien après la défense est le premier
pôle commercial des yvelines
c'est pour cette raison que le
territoire est intéressant pour les
start up mais tout d'abord nous allons
interviewé jean luc moreau le directeur
de ce qu'est cube
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes héros bonjour
bienvenue à skis que merci j'ai donné
quelques chiffres sur la création
d'entreprises sur le territoire
quels sont les outils qui sont à
disposition par 50 ans du v les outils
sont nombreux ils sont liés à la fois
l'accompagnement mais également au
financement à l'implantation
d'entreprises donc toute une palette de
services qui sont propres au territoire
de saint quentin pour la plupart d'entre
eux est adapté aux entreprises qui en
ont besoin
le tout réuni principalement dans une
logique de pôles de l'entrepreneuriat
l'innovation qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
ce qui est le directeur de cette entité
quels sont les points importants pour
pouvoir se lancer d'abord l'être bien
accompagné c'est un élément important et
c'est ce que nous souhaitons proposer
ici aux porteurs de projets aux
dirigeants d'entreprise de saint quentin
en yvelines
donc ça c'est pour la partie extérieure
mais en tous les cas pour le futur chef
d'entreprise qu'il est important c'est
effectivement de réunir toutes les
conditions à la fois les conditions
personnelles familiales mais également
toutes les conditions qui sont liées
produits projet lui-même pour pouvoir
trouver un marché et développer son
projet dans les meilleures conditions et
on va parler là à l'instant de l'un de
vos en cubes et faisons un conte sur la
start up aime tous et m
un fournisseur de solutions il fait
partie des premiers en cubes et voyant
son évolution au sein de la plateforme
c'est en 2015 que la start-up mpm voit
le jour les cinq fondateurs de
l'entreprise décide de mettre en place
une solution de gestion de l'éclairage
public grâce à leur dispositif
il compte réduire la facture
d'électricité des communes
leur but réduire le coût de l'éclairage
public qui représente 41% avec une
solution complète on va jusqu'à 85 % de
réduction mais ceux ci les amène à
remplacer également les les lampes
si on s'en tient uniquement à notre
solution sans parler de remplacement des
lampadaires
on va jusqu'à 35 % de réduction de la
facture ce qui est colossal et également
nous sommes capables de faire évoluer le
système pour prendre en compte des
nouvelles données dès demain une idée
innovante soutenu par le ski tube mpm
fait partie des premiers incubés avoir
intégré la structure pour julien fessard
c'est une aide précieuse
ils ont mis en place un partenariat avec
incuballiance qui est une association
qui est vraiment spécialisé dans le
suivi
et l'accompagnement des start up et donc
bénéficient d'un programme
d'accompagnement et d'un suivi
personnalisé puisque tous les projets
qui sont au sky cubes ont des niveaux
d'avancement différents
le rêve de l'entreprise et de pouvoir
équiper les communes de l'agglomération
de son système
mtu ayem est sollicité par le parc de la
vallée de chevreuse pour mettre en place
son dispositif
alors le ski tube existe depuis très peu
de temps et on voit des sociétés comme
aime tous et aime avancer
quelles sont vos missions comme on vous
les accompagnez alors d'abord nous
travaillons dans une logique de
partenariat nous avons un partenariat
très spécifique avec un incubateur privé
qui s'appelle incuballiance et dans
cette logique
d'ouverture les partenaires nous
proposons toute une palette d'outils à
la fois porté par la maison de
l'entreprise qui comme vous le savez a
développé ces derniers temps des les
outils plutôt généraliste losc mvs voile
alors à la fois sur le financement mais
également sur l'accompagnement nous
avons également une plate-forme rage
pour aider les entreprises à recruter
principalement donc ça c'est sûr le côté
généraliste de l'accompagnement et puis
un accompagnement très spécifique dédié
aux projets innovants et c'est là
qu'intervient notre prestataire
incuballiance pour aider les entreprises
dans leur logique produits dans leur
logique marché dans leur logique
financement dans leur logique
managériale donc le tout avec le
vraiment un esprit de complémentarité
dispositif pour permettre à ces startups
d'être accompagnés sur une durée qui
peut varier entre 6 et 24 mois et leur
permettre de se développer dans les
meilleures conditions sur notre
territoire et pour finir c'est quoi la
suite c'est quoi l'avenir comme le ski
cube un bel avenir c'est continuer
accompagner ces start peur faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent se développer
j'insiste sur le mauvais temps dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
et puis qu'on puisse se trouver de
futurs dirigeants d'entreprises qui
seront pourquoi problématique pour le
territoire de 50 ans du clip et bien je
vous remercie
merci de nous avoir reçu ce que je vous
en faire beaucoup de travail absolument
même c'était bienvenue ou bien merci à
vous médiateur bas mais le financement
des entreprises est important pour la
création d'une start up sur le
territoire nous annonce qu'un geste qui
permet de lever des fonds mais d'autres
outils sont mis à disposition pour aider
les startups
nous avons le cas de howden par kyle en
cours regardez c'est suite à un voyage
aux etats unis que christophe petits
découvrent le jump marque tout de suite
il a l'idée d'en faire un en france pour
financer son plan il fait le tour des
banques mais aucune d'elles ne donne du
crédit à son projet il décide donc de le
présenter à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
le principe étant que on vient présenter
son dossier devant un jury dont il ya un
passage tous les mois et un jury qui se
réunit et donc on passe un par un les
candidats où on expose son son dossier
on a fait un petit dossier un dossier
sur excel
on présente aux commandes du jury et une
dizaine de personnes composé de
banquiers d'experts comptables des
personnes de personnes delà de la
société civile privée comme des
entrepreneurs des choses comme ça il
obtient un prêt de l'agglomération en
juin 2016 avec son appui il obtient
aussi plus rapidement un crédit des
banques ce qui lui permet d'accélérer la
création du john parkes six mois après
ouverture du john parkes
le pari est réussi pour christophe petit
naïf et rassure vous verrez c'est ni
plus ni moins que voilà une structure
qui accueille
des gens de tout âge de tout horizon des
petits des grands familles on a mis des
enterrements de vie de garçon de jeunes
filles aulas banon c'est quelque chose
de très vastes et c'est un projet auquel
je suis très content et que apparemment
les gens aussi donc c'est plutôt
chouette
selon christophe outils le haut john
parkes remporté un franc succès pour le
moment du collabore avec les maisons de
quartiers de l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise
bonjour monsieur bonjour vous êtes le
directeur d'un club alliances dites moi
vous avez participé à la construction de
ce projet de ski cube
quelques mois plus tard qu'est ce que ça
donne écoutez ça fait effectivement six
mois que mes skis cuba était a priori
officiellement lancée et six mois après
je pense qu'on peut dire qu'il ya déjà
pas mal de choses concrètes qui sont sur
la table
nous avons sept projets incubés depuis
officiellement le 1er janvier si on s'en
tient aux termes administratifs des
projets aussi diverses que des plates
formes numériques que des projets pour
le bien-être
tendu adossé à la technologie et des
projets dans les écotechnologies aussi
voilà quels sont les ateliers qui les
aident à se former sur ce côté aussi
bien économique aller chercher le client
alors tous les projets qui ont été
incubés aussi qu'une passe par une sorte
de période intense de travail qu'on
appelle le genesis lab et au cours
desquelles sont organisés environ 40
ateliers de travail alors il ya des
ateliers travaillent sur ce qu'on
appelle la proposition de valeur c'est à
dire concrètement comment est ce qu'on
arrive à proposer quelque chose qui a de
la valeur pour un client potentiel
il y à des ateliers travaillent sur la
singularité qu'est ce qui fait que notre
proposition
notre offre est véritablement singulière
se différencie de ce qu'il y a de ce
qu'il y aura sur le marché ni à des
études travail bien sûr sur le modèle
financier comment est-ce qu'on génère
des revenus et comment est-ce qu'on peut
gagner de l'argent de nombreux ateliers
donc que effectivement une quarantaine
sur une période de deux mois et d'autres
ateliers sont encore prévues après dans
le cadre de l'incubation de manière plus
façon des ateliers beaucoup plus
thématiques beaucoup plus pointu vous
qu'il y avait ce recul sur les clusters
aussi ce type d'entité les grosses
entreprises elle jette un coup d'oeil
quand même à ce type de lieu
oui tous ces industriels sont aux prises
avec le problème de l'innovation ils
doivent innover
ils savent que l'innovation ne passe
plus uniquement par leur service de
recherche et développement que cette
innovation doit s'ouvrir ce qu'on
appelle l'innovation ouverte et que par
conséquent ils doivent venir dans des
lieux comme le ski tubes pour s'inspirer
de ce qui se passe et parfois se
rapprocher des start up qui sont en
création ici j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
plans des clients avec des entreprises
dans l'aéronautique sans les citer on
attendra que ça se fasse
vous derrière quand vous savez qu'il ya
des ce type d'entreprise qui se
rapprochent vous les conseillez vous
allez au rendez vous avec eux ont fait
mieux que cela c'est à dire que on on
considère qu'une partie de l'eau travail
ça consiste à mettre en rapport les
grandes entreprises du territoire ou
d'ailleurs mais parce qu un territoire
avec ces projets là de façon à ce qu
effectivement puisse se crée parfois des
premières expérimentations il ya là
encore une fois ne parlons pas trop vite
mais étant en train de se mettre en
place une expérimentation avec un grand
centre commercial de saint quentin en
yvelines est l'une de nos startups donc
c'est quelque chose de très concret
après on n'est pas sur le terrain en
train de faire l'expérimentation avec
une c'est ce rôle s'arrête avant avec
plaisir versement à très bientôt et on
passe au jt de l'écho
[Musique]
le 3 mai un grand forum jobs d'été de
l'apprentissage était programmé au
gymnase guimier attrape l'événement a
attiré plus d'une quarantaine
d'entreprises et samson jeunes curieux
le but pour nous ça va être de trouver
notamment des stagiaires des alternants
cdd cdi qui pourrait correspondre dans
khan aux offres la société antemeta
située à guyancourt experte dans le
stockage des données d entreprise vient
de racheter ces stores âge une
entreprise spécialisée dans la
protection des données
c'est sa toute première opération de
croissance externe et elle souhaite avec
seul à dépasser le chiffre d'affaires de
60 à 70 millions avant la fin de l'année
la poste qui compte plus de 2000
postiers dans les yvelines va gonfler
ses effectifs d'ici la fin de l'année
2010 est une centaine de cdi sur une
base de 35 heures sont proposés le
double de l'année dernière
objectif accompagner la transformation
des secteurs de l'entreprise
qu'effectivement de recruter de recruter
des personnels qui eux vont nous
permettre de renforcer notre notre force
de travail donc ça ça reste important
et puis n'oubliez pas votre déclaration
de revenus cela concerne plus de 750
mille contribuables dans les yvelines
vous avez jusqu'au 6 juin avant minuit
pour le faire sur internet on passe à
l'agenda premières dates à noter imagine
mobility forum c'est de 9h à 18h à
l'estac à montigny le bretonneux mode de
déplacement mode de vie modalités
collective et individuelle en bas nisme
sociologie quelles innovations pour
demain vous saurez tout lors de ce forum
et puis rendez vous le jeudi 1er juin
2017 au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour le départ de la
10e édition du trophée des entreprises
les inscriptions sont ouvertes penser
dès à présent à constituer vos équipes
de trois personnes celle à prendre se
situe t co merci de nous avoir suivis et
surtout bonne journée à tous
[Musique]